Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wunder gibt es immer wieder, unter anderem, dass im Rasenfunk auch über die 2. Liga gesprochen wird. Das will ich jetzt tun, mit Daniel Rossbach vom Textilvergehen, unter anderem hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Daniel, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Hi.
Ja, hallo Max.
Wie schön, mit dir zu sprechen und wie schön, dass wir mal über die 2. Liga hier sprechen können, bevor die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Also ich vermute, ich moderiere gerade in einen tosenen Applaus hinein. In der Straßenbahn, unter der Dusche, beim Einkaufen, beim Putzen. Die Leute werden Standing und Welchens geben. Endlich 2. Liga im Rasenfunk. Kriegt euch ein, Leute. Beruhigt euch. Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus. Es wird jetzt Kurzpass ergeben. Der Plan ist bis zum Ende der Saison. Mal gucken, ob ich den Plan überhaupt halten kann. Und danach müssen wir dann mal schauen, wie war das jetzt von der Resonanz her? Hat es euch überhaupt gefallen? Wie war es vom Aufwand her? Ging es für mich? Und wie war es für Gäste wie Daniel, die sich halt dann schon mit einem Moderator rumschlagen müssen, der dann doch noch mal verschämt den neuen Trainer von Darmstadt 98 googelt vor der Sendung? Also müssen wir noch alles evaluieren. Aber Daniel, schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Man kennt dich vom Textilvergehen-Podcast. Sehr empfehlenswert. Du schreibst auf eisernerketten.de aus taktischer Sicht über Union Berlin. Deswegen werden wir heute natürlich auch über Union sprechen. Und du bist bei der Lausitzer Rundschau unterwegs. Freut mich sehr, einen Podcast-Urgestein ja fast schon mit dabei zu haben.
Naja, Textilvergehen gibt es ja schon ein bisschen länger, als ich da mitmache. Von daher das mit dem Urgestein, naja. Aber ich freue mich auf jeden Fall sehr, hier zu sein. Und ich würde mich auch sonst und vielleicht auch trotzdem freuen, die Folge zu hören.
Ach ja, das ist schön, dass du auch den Rasenfunk hörst. Du bist ein sehr netter Mensch. Aber jetzt lass mal gleich in die Liga rein gucken, weil es gibt ja durchaus einiges zu besprechen in der 2. Liga, was ja schon ganz oben anfängt. Dann werden wir uns mit dem Ausstiegsrennen befassen. Und da sah es beim 1. FC Köln so aus, als wären die schon sicher durch. Und sie müssten jetzt eigentlich nur noch den Sack zumachen. Und dann kommt irgendwie so ein 4-4 in Duisburg, ein 1-1 zu Hause gegen den HSV, jetzt ein 0-3 in Dresden. Was ist denn da beim FC passiert, dass man jetzt zwar immer noch acht Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz hat, bei noch zwölf auszuspielenden Punkten, aber dass man da jetzt so die Konsequenz vermissen lässt in diesen Spielen?
Also, dass man in Dresden immer noch hoch verliert, ist ja auch irgendwie schon so ein bisschen Tradition für Mannschaften, die aufsteigen. Wir erinnern uns das Stuttgart da mal, ich glaube, 5 zu 0 und 3 zu 0 in einer Saison, also in der Saison, in der sie neulich in der 2. Liga waren, verloren hat. Aber insgesamt ist es, glaube ich, bei Köln so, dass sie tatsächlich sich relativ stark auf ihre internationale Qualität verlassen. Das sah am Anfang der Saison noch ein bisschen weniger danach aus, war dann aber immer mehr der Fall. Und dann ist man natürlich auch anfälliger für einerseits Vorschwankungen und vielleicht auch für so ein gewisses Maß an Konsequenz, das vielleicht verloren geht, wenn man eben acht, zehn Punkte Vorschwung auf den Nicht-Aufstiegsplatz hat. Und das scheint da so ein bisschen zu passieren. Aber ich glaube, dass es trotzdem extrem unwahrscheinlich ist, dass Köln nicht erster wird und auf jeden Fall aufsteigt.
Ja gut, aber so meinem Eindruck nach könnte das der schlecht gelaunteste Aufsteiger seit ganz langem werden. Ich habe das Gefühl, im 1. FC Köln Lager brodelt das richtig. Und ich hatte eigentlich auch Markus Anfang, der ja von Holstein Kiel zum FC gewechselt ist vor dieser Saison. Den hatte ich eigentlich auch als Trainer in Erinnerung, der einen eher systemischen Fußball spielen lässt. Täuscht mich jetzt da meine Erinnerung oder lässt er was beim FC vermissen, was man sonst bei ihm gesehen hat?
Nee, das ist auf jeden Fall richtig, was du als deine Erinnerung angibst. Denn bei Kiel hat Anfang tatsächlich sehr interessanten Fußball spielen lassen letztes Jahr und hat da eben auch eine Mannschaft gehabt, die zwar größere Inimative Qualität hatte, als man das von so einem durchschnittlichen Aufsteiger vermuten würde, die aber auf jeden Fall noch insgesamt kollektiv overperformed hat. Da waren ihm ein paar sehr interessante Stilmittel auch dabei, die man bei Köln jetzt sich auch gut hätte vorstellen können, weil gerade die Rolle der Außenverteidiger, die es bei Kiel gab, da dachte ich mir, wenn man jetzt sowieso einen der stärksten Spieler der Mannschaft und der Liga in dieser Position hat, die dann so besonders betont wird im Spielaufbau, also mit Jonas Hektor, dann könnte das eigentlich ein großes Potenzial haben. Und in den ersten Spielen sah man das auch noch, aber dann wurde es eben irgendwie kontinuzieller. Und es gehört zu den Rätseln, die sich mir in dieser Zweitligasaison stellen, warum das eigentlich genauso ist und warum Marius Anfang scheinbar weniger innovativ jetzt bei einem größeren, luxuriöser ausgestatteten Verein arbeitet, als er das vorher getan hat. Andererseits ist natürlich richtig, was du sagst, dass in Köln man damit jetzt nicht so zwingend zufrieden ist. Aber es ist trotzdem auch ein bisschen schwierig, wirklich große Vorwürfe zu machen, wenn die Mannschaft halt erster ist. Also, weil man sich fragen kann, wenn sie noch stärker gefordert wären oder anders gefordert wären, würden sie dann vielleicht noch auf andere Dinge kommen. Aber das ist so ein komisches, kontrafaktisches Gebilde, was nicht ganz einfach aufzulösen ist. Aber insgesamt kann man sagen, dass sie halt einfach qua der Mannschaft, die sie haben, in diese Liga aufsteigen müssen und das halt auch tun. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall glanzvoller sein könnte, als es jetzt ist.
Ja, es ist schon irgendwie eine komische Situation. Also der FC hat mit weitem Abstand die meisten Tore der Liga geschossen, 75. Wenn wir dann gleich noch über den HSV sprechen, die liegen bei 34 Toren weniger. Simon Terodde allein 28 Treffer gemacht. Also von den Ergebnissen her stimmt es irgendwie. Ich meine, man hat natürlich viel mehr den Ball als vielleicht noch Markus Anfang bei Holstein Kiel. Also im Ballbesitz sind natürlich der HSV mit 57 Prozent und dann schon der FC mit 55 Prozent. Das sind die Mannschaften, die in der Regel die Spielkontrolle haben und dann vermutlich halt auch gegen tieferstehende Gegner agieren. Vielleicht ist das auch so ein Element, was da aus taktischer Sicht noch dazu kommt.
Ja, das mit den tieferstehenden Gegnern ist auf jeden Fall ein Punkt. Denn was Kieler letztes Jahr so interessant gemacht hat, war eben, wie sie gegen gegen das Pressing das aufgelöst haben. Und dazu hat man bei Köln jetzt sicherlich ein bisschen weniger gelegen. Aber bei Besitz betont war Kiel schon auch, von daher weiß ich nicht, ob das der hauptsächliche Unterschied ist. Man kann ja auf jeden Fall noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass Simon Thurotte natürlich der herausstechende Spieler ist, qua dieser Toranzahl, die aber auch so ein bisschen die Folge ist, dass man als der zentrale Stürmer von Köln, der dann auch im meisten spielt, natürlich auch viele Chancen bekommt. Und Thurotte hat jetzt 28 Tore in 2200 Minuten geschossen, John Cordova hat 16 Tore in 1700 Minuten geschossen. Das ist ja nicht eine so viel schlechtere Quote. Und auf jeden Fall muss man dabei noch Dominik Trexler erwähnen, der ja auch mit Anfang auf komplizierte, ein bisschen fragwürdige Weise von Kiel über Dänemark nach Köln gewechselt ist.
Und jetzt auch wieder. Ach ja, genau, das war ja die Nummer. Genau, da gab es nicht den direkten Wechsel, weil es direkt irgendwie untersagt war.
Ja, und dann dachte man, er würde zu einem dänischen Champions-League-Teil in Mütchwiland wechseln, aber das war dann doch nicht so, das war ein bisschen fishy. Aber jedenfalls hat Trexler jetzt, war in der letzten Saison der beste Spieler der Liga, hat jetzt auch wieder einen neuen Tor geschossen und elf vorbereitet und ist eben jemand, der aber auch letztes Jahr noch systematischer hervorragend eingebunden war. Und jetzt sieht man dann einfach, dass er immer noch ein sehr guter Fußballer ist, der sehr gut darin ist, entscheidende Pässe zu spielen und eben auch selber in Abschlusssituationen zu kommen. Aber das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz gutes Beispiel dafür, wie anfangs herangehendsweise letztes Jahr vielleicht ein bisschen systematischer war als dieses Jahr.
Also es geht jetzt dann noch in den restlichen vier Spielen gegen Darmstadt, nach Fürth, gegen Regensburg und nach Magdeburg. Das heißt, die Chancen auf den Ausstieg sind sehr, sehr groß beim 1. FC Köln und in welcher Laune man das tut, das kann man ja dann irgendwie auch für sich selbst entscheiden. Und vor allem hat man den großen Vorteil, dass man mit dem Aufstieg relativ sicher planen kann. Wenn ich mir jetzt aber dahinter mal den HSV anschaue, da tut sich einiges Erstaunliches. Aus den letzten fünf Spielen zwei Niederlagen, drei Unentschieden. Damit liegt man jetzt bei 53 Punkten und hat nur noch zwei Punkte Vorsprung auf Paderborn, drei Punkte Vorsprung auf Union Berlin, vier Punkte Vorsprung auf Heidenheim. Also wie die Polkappen schmilzt der Vorsprung des HSV langsam dahin. Und die Frage ist, was kann man dagegen tun? Freitagsdemonstrationen muss man jetzt Schüler aktivieren. Was ist los beim HSV?
Dann wieder abspielt er mich. Du hast gesagt, dass der Vorsprung schmilzt. Natürlich tut er das nur auf Paderborn, die jetzt vier Liga-Unternehmen aus den letzten fünf Spielen steht.
Er sollte schmelzen, aber er tut es nicht.
Union hat ja genau den selben Rekord über die letzten fünf Spiele. Was bei Hamburg das Problem ist, ist, dass sie ja tatsächlich nicht gut Fußball spielen. Sie haben einen Kader, der nicht auf allen Positionen so viel besser ist als der aller anderen. Es gibt natürlich Spieler, die in diese Liga herausstechen. Einerseits solche wie Aaron Hunt oder Luis Holtby, die nicht in jedem Spiel, aber in vielen Spielen, sichtbar machen, dass sie besser sind. So wie Douglas Santos und vor allem auch Oren Mangala, der aus Stuttgart ausgeliehen ist. Das könnte auch noch eine interessante Situation sein, wo man eigentlich davon ausgehen würde, dass er auf jeden Fall zurückgehen muss. Aber wenn sich diese Fahne überkreuzen, dann wäre das vielleicht noch interessant zu sehen. Aber es gibt eben auch etliche Personen, die eher so ein bisschen durchschnittlich besetzt sind, gerade so im zentralen Mittelfeld, auch in der Innenverteidigung, wo es dann eben nicht dazu kommt, dass Hamburg dominant spielt in dieser Liga. Und es gibt dann eben Spiele, das gegen Pöhrt war ja so eins, wo ihnen halt wirklich extrem wenig eingefallen ist, wo es eigentlich das ganze Spiel nur daraus bestand, zu versuchen, Vakarijicata in Laufduelle zu schicken gegen den jeweiligen Außenverteidiger auf der Seite dann und dann zu hoffen, dass er diese Laufduelle gewinnt und dass da vernünftige Reingaben herauskommen. Das hat dann in dem Spiel auch irgendwann funktioniert, und das war insofern ein bisschen sinnwürdig für die Saison, dass irgendwie sie dann immer noch ein Tor schießen. Aber sie machen einfach relativ wenig aus ihrer individuellen Qualität. Dann kommen halt solche Spiele zustande, wie jetzt am letzten Wochenende, wo sie gegen Auer gespielt haben. Wo Auer in dem Spiel tatsächlich so gespielt hat, wie man sich das vielleicht creschierend wie sich vorstellt, wenn Auer beim Hamburger SV spielt und dann zwischendurch ein Tor geschossen hat. Und Hamburg dann auch gar nicht so viele richtig große Chancen hatte. Dann hat Hand noch einen Freischuss diesmal eben an die Date geschossen und nicht ins Tor. Und es gab halt doch relativ viele Spiele, in denen diese eine Aktion dann noch funktioniert hat, in der an einer Stelle die individuelle Qualität dann noch gereicht hat, um ein Tor zu machen. Aber wenn man sich auch das Torverhältnis von Hamburg anschaut, das bei plus 8 liegt und damit ja sich doch deutlich aus dem, aus dem der anderen Aufstiegskandidaten unten rausfällt, dann sieht man, dass da eben die Mannschaft eher noch in der Tabelle besser dasteht, als sie in der Saison gespielt hat.
Also 41 Tore eben nur erzielt, 33 kassiert, so kommen diese plus 8 zustande, um das kurz in einen Kontext zu setzen. 41 Tore hat zum Beispiel auch der VfL Bochum erzielt. Das ist so die Range, in der man sich dann bewegt beim HSV. Jetzt hätte ich Hannes Wolf als einen Trainer eingeschätzt, der es durchaus schafft, durch taktische Maßnahmen einen nicht optimal besetzten Kader zu kaschieren. Zeigt er jetzt eine andere Seite, als wir sie von ihm gesehen haben in der Aufstiegssaison vom VfB Stuttgart? Bin ich da zu weit weg? Und meine Erinnerung ist dazu schön gefärbt. Bin ich vielleicht VfB-Nostalger in der Rückschau? Wie würdest du denn seine Rolle beim HSV bewerten?
Ich würde das eigentlich gar nicht anders sehen, was die Zeit in Stuttgart anbetrifft. Da gab es jetzt ein paar Spiele, wo Stuttgart, wie gesagt, auch lindelang erfahren hat, die man vielleicht nicht erwartet hätte. Aber es gab eben auch Spiele, wo sie dann auch deutlich besser waren als die anderen Mannschaften, die damals in den Aufstieg konkurriert haben. Das war damals Hannover, Braunschweig und Union. Eigentlich ist es so ein bisschen ähnlich wie bei Anfang, dass ich auch gar nicht so genau weiß, warum da nicht mehr passiert inhaltlich, taktisch in dieser Saison. Aber dass man davon enttäuscht sein kann, das würde ich auf jeden Fall beschreiben.
Und vor allem mit Blick auf das, was noch kommt. Wir nehmen ja jetzt auf, nach dem 30. Spieltag beim 1. FC Köln habe ich mit Blick auf das Restprogramm gesagt, ok, gut, das sollte irgendwie klappen beim HSV, bin ich mir da von außen betrachtet nicht so sicher. Es geht jetzt dann nach Berlin zu Union, da wirst du natürlich ganz genau drauf schon auf dieses Spiel. Dann spielt man zu Hause noch gegen Ingolstadt und Duisburg, also zwei Mannschaften, die unten drin stehen, um jeden Punkt kämpfen. Vielleicht die größte Hoffnung für den HSV, dass Duisburg am 34. Spieltag um nichts mehr zu kämpfen hat, wobei da natürlich auch eine Gefahr drin liegt. Und man wird auch noch in Paderborn spielen. Also du hast zwei direkte Aufstiegskonkurrenten und zwei Mannschaften aus dem allerletzten Tabellendrittel, die ja auch jetzt gerade gar keine so schlechte Phase haben. Werden wir später auch noch drüber sprechen. Hältst du es für realistisch, dass das tatsächlich noch so schief geht, dass man in die Relegation und im schlimmsten Fall sogar noch tiefer fällt?
Also ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass Paderborn gegen den HSV gewinnt. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass Union gegen den HSV gewinnt am Wochenende. Und dann würde ich es ungefähr 50-50 sehen zwischen einem direkten Aufstiegsplatz und gar keinem Aufstieg für den HSV.
Gut, jetzt warten wir erstmal ab, wie sie gegen Rasen bei Sport Leipzig im DFB-Pokal abschneiden. Das ist jetzt nochmal so ein Zwischen-Event, aber beim HSV sehr, sehr interessante Position. Und das hast du mich ja vorhin schon vollkommen richtig korrigiert, als ich vom schmelzenden Vorsprung gesprochen habe, dass sich das eigentlich nur auf zwei Mannschaften beziehen lässt, nämlich auf Paderborn und Heidenheim. Union werden wir gleich darüber sprechen, warum das da irgendwie nicht so läuft. Aber Paderborn, das ist ja unglaublich. Vier Siege aus den letzten fünf Spielen haben die zweitmeisten Tore geschossen. Das ist so der typische SC-Paderborn-Fußball, an dem man sich also in den Aufstiegssaisonen spielt. Das ist immer so. Es gibt dann auch den Paderborn-Fußball in den Abstiegsspielzeiten, aber das ist jetzt eine andere Nummer. Jetzt sehen wir gerade wieder das offensive Paderborn hinten nicht immer sattelfest. Also in den Spielen mit Paderborn sind 111 Tore gefallen. Da ist immer was los, kann man jedem empfehlen. Die haben zwei Punkte Rückstand auf den HSV, ein Punkt Vorsprung auf Union. Was macht den Paderborn so stark oder macht den Paderborn etwas anders, was viele Zweitligisten ansonsten nicht auf den Platz bekommen?
Also Paderborn hat relativ direkt die Rolle von Kiel aus der letzten Saison übernommen des Aufsteigers, der einen besseren Grad hat, als man denken würde und vor allem eine extrem klare fußballische Linie hat, die sie extrem klar verfolgen. Man muss daher dazu sagen, dass Steffen Baumgart da vor jetzt gut an knapp zwei Jahren oder so Trainer wurde, also am Ende der vorigen Drittligasong, der Paderborn eigentlich abgestiegen ist, aber durch den Failing 1860 vereint, gerettet wurde. Und dann deswegen in der Liga bleiben durfte, dann letztendlich ziemlich überragend aufgestiegen ist oder ziemlich überlegen. Und jetzt genauso spielt wie in der dritten Liga, nämlich mit einem extrem schnell, extrem vertikalen und extrem druckvollen Fußball, wo sie ein paar herausragende Spieler haben, also Philipp Klemenz muss man natürlich da nennen, der 15 Tore geschossen hat als zentraler Mittelfeldspieler, der oft wirklich eher so noch die tiefere 6. Rolle spielt, das ist schon ziemlich verrückt. Da sind natürlich viele Freistöße und ich glaube auch ein paar Elfmeter dabei, aber auch einfach viele Tore aus dem Spiel heraus. Und Steffen Warngardt hat da einfach eine Mannschaft, die ziemlich bedingungslos nach vorne spielt, die aber schon noch dazu fähig ist, das ein Stück weit zu dosieren. Also jetzt zum Beispiel gegen Kiel haben sie im Hinspiel 4-4 gespielt, weil Paderborn da aggressiv gepresst hat und Kiel vollkommen jedes Risiko, das möglich war, eingegangen ist im Aufbau und dann kamen viele Chancen auf beiden Seiten und den Chancen angemessenes 4-4 raus. Das war jetzt diesmal ein bisschen anders, ein bisschen vorsichtiger und endete dann auch ein 2-1-Sieg für Paderborn, der natürlich sehr wichtig war, einerseits um Kiel so ein bisschen auf Distanz zu halten und sich selber eben so zu positionieren, wie wir es gerade schon erwähnt haben. Und dann gibt es halt noch ein paar andere Spieler, die für diese Liga schon ein bemerkenswertes Niveau haben, also jemand wie Bernhard Tekpitej, der ich glaube entweder aus Schalke ausgeliehen oder gewechselt ist und durchaus eine hohe Leistungsspanne hat, aber eben auch ein hohes oberes Ende dieser Spanne. Sebastian Vassiliades ist ein 6er, 8er, der extrem gut ist, Verbindungen ins Mittelfeld zu schaffen, was bei vielen Mannschaften auch in dieser Liga so ein bisschen die Krux ist. Das ist da aber auch quasi individueller Qualität und aus der Bereitschaft dieser Risiken da auch zu gehen, spielerische Lösungen zu suchen, gegeben. Und dann gibt es eben noch ein paar andere Spieler, die einfach gut zu ihren Rollen passen. Und so ist Paderborn halt eine ernsthaft gute Mannschaft.
Also Teg Petey ist tatsächlich für 150.000 Euro vor dieser Saison vom FC Schalke 04 fix gewechselt zum SC Paderborn, für die es jetzt dann weitergeht. Man hat jetzt mit Holstein Kiel einen Mitkonkurrenten um den Aufstieg auf Distanz gehalten. Direkt der Nächste wartet noch im Heimspiel jetzt dann gegen Heidenheim, über die werden wir auch noch sprechen. Dann geht es nach Bielefeld. Dann ein Heimspiel, vorhin schon angesprochen, gegen den HSV, bevor man dann nach Dresden reist. Also auch ein interessanter Nächster-Spiel-Tag wartet da auf uns in der 2. Liga. Das muss man wirklich so sagen. Und erst jetzt kommen wir zu Union Berlin, deinem Herzensverein und dem Verein, der irgendwie schon immer so ein bisschen da oben mitspielt, aber die letzte Konsequenz, wie man so unschön sagt, im Aufstiegskampf vermissen lässt und auch so die eine oder andere Trainer-Pyruette gedreht hat, die von außen nicht immer einsichtig war, wenn man dann das Textilvergehen gehört hat, hat man es meistens wieder besser nachvollziehen können. 50 Punkte hat Union 14 unentschieden, da liegt der Hase ein bisschen begraben, zu wenige Siege aus gut gespielten Spielen herausgeholt, eben aus den letzten fünf Partien, zwei Niederlagen und jetzt drei unentschieden in Folge. Man hat einen Punkt Rückstand auf Paderborn, man hat drei Punkte Rückstand auf den direkten Aufstiegsplatz. Was ist da los bei Union?
Tja, das ist eine große Frage jetzt.
Vor allem für den Kurzpass, sorry.
Also man muss vielleicht noch mal kurz bei dem, was du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, auch sagen, dieses Narrativ, dass ich da jetzt so rausgebildet habe, dass Union irgendwie ständig nah dran ist im Aufstieg und dann irgendwie es immer doch nicht schafft, das ist halt ein bisschen schief, weil eigentlich so eine Saison, wo sie wirklich nah dran waren und es dann nicht gereicht hat, gab es eigentlich erst einmal in den letzten Jahren, in den zehn Jahren seit Union jetzt in der zweiten Liga spielt, nämlich vor zwei Jahren eben, als sie dann die Auswärtsspiele in Hannover, Braunschweig und Stuttgart jeweils verloren haben und dann einfach auch letztlich nicht ganz gut genug waren. Also da war es nicht so ein Versagen oder psychologisches Einbrechen oder so, sondern es hat einfach dann nicht ganz gereicht im Vergleich zu diesen anderen Mannschaften.
Man war halt jetzt zweimal Vierter in den letzten drei Jahren. Wahrscheinlich kommt dieses Narrativ daher, nur ist halt der vierte Platz nicht immer so zustande gekommen, wie es jetzt gerade aussieht und wie es damals war.
Also ich glaube, man war nur einmal Vierter, wenn ich mich gerade nicht…
2016, 2017 war er ein junger Vierter und… Ach so, ach ja, du hast völlig recht. Der Max, es ist sehr früh am Morgen, der Max hat einfach die aktuelle Platzierung mit reingerechnet. Super, super Move, Max. Vielleicht habe ich damit aber auch gejinkst.
Und genau, in der letzten Saison war man zwar am Ende dann irgendwie noch Sechster, Siebter, hat aber wie die ganze Liga die ganze Zeit zwischen Absteigen und Aufsteigen und den Möglichkeiten von Beiden changiert. Und davor gab es ein paar Saisons, wo Unionen wirklich auch gar nichts mit dem Aufstieg zu tun hat. Von daher ist das so ein bisschen so ein Expost-Narrativ, das sich da so rausgebildet hat und was dann nach dieser Saison vielleicht langsam Berechtigung haben könnte, wenn das jetzt so ausgeht.
Aber hat es nicht auch Berechtigung von den Amitionen von Unionen beliebt? Entschuldige, wenn ich da nochmal reingehe. Also Unionen nimmt ja auch wirklich Geld in die Hand. Man hat jetzt häufig trainiert, rotiert auf der Trainerposition. Also im Grunde, seitdem der ewige Uwe Neuhaus gegangen ist, hatte man jetzt, wenn ich mir allein nur die Trainer angucke, die am Ende einer Saison da waren, dann hat das jetzt einfach fünfmal gewechselt. Norbert Dübel, André Hofschneider, Jens Keller, nochmal André Hofschneider, Urs Fischer.
Ja, auf die Ambition wollte ich auch gerade zu sprechen kommen. Die sind auf jeden Fall da. Da hat man ja gerade vor der letzten Saison auch sehr wenig Held rumgemacht. Dann kam man aber in der letzten Saison aus einer Phase, wo man auf Platz 4 liegend, wie du vorhin schon angedeutet hast, Jens Keller entlassen hat. Das war aber auch vollkommen nachvollziehbar, weil es eben sportlich nicht in eine Richtung ging, von der man erwarten konnte, dass in der Saison noch was wird mit den Zielen. Die waren dann relativ deutlich verfehlt worden. An dem grundsätzlichen Anspruch von den Jungen hat sich deswegen nichts geändert. Man will immer noch aufsteigen, man investiert auch immer noch in eine Weise in diese Mannschaft, die das durchaus möglich machen sollte. Es gab ja auch schon ein paar ambitionierte Transfers, wie Carlos Manet, den man vielleicht noch aus Stuttgart kennt, wie Robert Schuhl, den man aus Hoffnung eben nicht so richtig kennt, aber der da auch mal war.
Das reicht ja manchmal schon. Bei Nico Willig wird jetzt gesagt, er hatte eine Fahrgemeinschaft mit Julian Nagelsmann und Domenico Griesko. Also es reicht schon, wenn du in der Ära warst im Donzengreis von irgendjemanden, der mal Erfolg hat.
Genau. Also das sind auf jeden Fall Spieler, die in der 2. Liga zum Individuell Besseren gehören. Auch Sebastian Poulter ist auf jeden Fall zu nennen, auch Manuel Schmidbach. Aber trotzdem war es so, dass man vor dieser Saison ein bisschen verunsicht von der Letzten war und dann erst einmal nur ausgegeben hat, sich verbessern zu wollen im Vergleich zu dieser Saison. Das würde bedeuten Platz 1 bis 6. Auch das kennt man bei Union als Ziel. Das gibt es schon seit ein paar Jahren. Und man hat eigentlich vor dieser Saison nicht zwingend geglaubt, dass man einer der Top-Anwärter auf den Aufstieg sein würde. Und es hat auch ein bisschen gedauert, bis man diese Mannschaft als Aufstiegskandidat so richtig ernst genommen hat. Und die Aufgabe von Urs Fischer war, irgendwie diese Mannschaft zu stabilisieren. Das hat er auch auf jeden Fall sehr gut hinbekommen. Sie ist jetzt ein bisschen zu stabil, wie du mit den 14 Unentschieden angesprochen hast. Und es fehlen so ein bisschen die Upside, was gerade das spielerische Potenzial angeht. Da gab es jetzt ein paar Spiele, in denen sich dann so ein bisschen angedeutet hat, dass es besser werden könnte im letzten Saisondrittel nochmal. Was man da für Hoffnung hatte, wurde relativ stark tief gefrostet von diesem letzten Spiel in Fürth, das schon einigermaßen für unsichernd schlecht war. Und wo man jetzt auch nochmal abwarten muss, ob das so ein Ausrutscher auf individueller oder sehr breit gestreuter individueller und kollektiver Ebene war und ob man da jetzt nochmal in eine andere Richtung rauskommt oder nicht.
Aber wenn ich mir jetzt mal die Statistiken angucke und es gibt leider, zumindest habe ich sie nicht gefunden, keine Expected Goals zur 2.
Doch, die gibt es tatsächlich. Wo finde ich die? Die gibt es bei 538 und da gibt es die Spiel für Spiel und es gibt bei den Dingen von St. Pauli Stats, st.paulistats.blogspot.com, da gibt es auch eine Zusammenstellung.
Okay, wie sieht es denn dann nach den Expected Points aus? Ich wollte jetzt gerade den Punkt machen, dass in der Defensive Union die Mannschaft ist, interessanterweise hinter Magdeburg und Bielefeld, die am wenigsten Schüsse in Richtung des eigenen Tores zulässt und dass man offensiv die vierte beste Mannschaft ist, mit den meisten Schüssen aufs Gegentor. Also es sieht eigentlich wunderbar aus, wenn ich mir das angucke und wenn ich dann gleichzeitig so viele Unentschieden sehe, dann wittert mein Statistiker-Näschen, dass man Spiele einfach nicht zumacht und in den Expected Goals ein bisschen Pech hat.
Also lustigerweise hat Union 39 Tore geschossen und hat 39, 02 Expected Goals.
Okay, meine Nase ist noch verschnupft. Okay, das war sehr eindeutig.
Ah nee, ich sehe gerade, das ist nicht ganz auf dem neuesten Stand, aber das ist ein paar Wochen alt, aber jedenfalls vor ein paar Spieltagen war es so, dass Union auf der defensiven Seite eher noch ein bisschen besser war in den Ergebnissen, in den Expected Goals und man muss eben auch dazu sagen, dass einige von den Tumpen, die Union geholt hat, schon auf der eher glücklichen Seite waren, wenn man sich die Spiele angeschaut hat und sich das jetzt eben in den letzten, in diesen fünf Spielen, die Union jetzt nicht gewonnen hat, teilweise so ein bisschen korrigiert hat. Also Spiele wie das gegen Dresden, wo es jetzt einen Unentschieden gab, hätte man bei dem Glück aus der Hinrunde sicherlich gewonnen. Das war eben jetzt nicht mehr so. Und insgesamt haben vielleicht dann doch die Spiele, wo man wirklich deutlich überlegen war, ein bisschen gefehlt. Und vielleicht gab es davon dann doch ein paar zu wenige. Und es ist ja trotzdem noch sehr, eigentlich sehr schwierig gegen Union zu gewinnen, weil sie grundsätzlich defensiv sehr solide sind und ein paar auch überragende Spieler in der Defensive haben, die einfach in dieser Liga auch ein Stück weit dominierend waren. Also Rafa Kikovic, den Torwart kann man da auf jeden Fall nennen, und die Innenverteidiger Florian Hübner und Marvin Friedrich haben auch lange eine sehr dominante Saison gespielt. Wurden jetzt teilweise ein bisschen schlechter aussehen lassen von Gegnern, die sie in großräumigere Laufteile gezwungen haben. Das ist nicht so ihr Spiel, aber da hat sich in ein paar Spielen bemerkbar gemacht, dass Unionen diesen Druck aufsteigen zu wollen, zu müssen. Und dann eben Spiel auch immer mehr gewinnen zu müssen als die Gegner in den letzten paar Partien. Das war dann auch auf taktischer, strategischer Ebene gar nicht so eine gute Ausführungsposition in einigen dieser Spiele.
Ach, ich finde das so schön. Jetzt haben wir auch so einen typischen Daniel – nicht Neologismus, aber ein Daniel-Logismus – hier im Rasenfunk gehabt. In der letzten Textilvergehen-Folge gab es Opportunitätsmaximieren. Und hier hast du jetzt von größerflächigen Laufduellen gesprochen. Und ich glaube, das war nur eine verkappte Formulierung von, die sind dann auf die letzten Meter zu langsam.
Also, was ich damit meinte, weil das Union im Insolidation ist, relativ viel in die Offensive investieren zu müssen, auch weil sie vielleicht systematisch nicht ganz so viele Lösungen finden und das dann mit Investment von Außenverteidigungen, die sehr hoch gehen, ausgleichen müssen. Und dann ist eben relativ viel Platz in der eigenen Hälfte übrig, den dann die Innenverteidigung, die Sechser und vielleicht ein Außenverteidiger, der dann noch rechtzeitig zurückkommt, verteidigen muss. Und in so Spielen wie gegen Ingolstadt zu Hause auch, vor allem gegen Regensburg, hat man eben gesehen, wie man dann diesen Platz und diese nicht ganz große Stärke der Schnelligkeit der beiden Unterteidiger, wie man die angreifen kann.
Wie wichtig ist denn jetzt dann dieses Heimspiel gegen den HSV? Also, dass man jetzt mit einem Sieg wieder voll in der Verlosung drin wäre, das ist ja sowieso klar. Ich glaube, allein schon ein Unentschieden würde ja dann auch den Trend fortsetzen aus den letzten fünf Spielen. Glaubst du, das ist jetzt auch die Partie, auf die es jetzt richtig ankommt, wenn man dann guckt, danach geht es noch gegen Darmstadt, gegen Magdeburg und gegen Bochum?
Also, einer der Journalisten-Kollegen hat am Wochenende das Spiel als eins der größten der Vereinsgeschichte bezeichnet und ich habe dann mal so ein bisschen…
Es könnte auch gegen die Vereinsgeschichte sprechen, aber…
Ich habe da mal so ein bisschen im Kopf überlegt, welche man da noch so nennen könnte und jetzt war dann mir nicht ganz sicher, ob man die Europapokalspiele gegen HK. Waikowski – ich habe vor oder dahinter – einsortiert. Ja, also es ist ein unfassbar wichtiges Spiel natürlich, wo man eben auch so den für die Saison emotionalen Neustart eben vielleicht hinbekommen könnte, indem man gewinnt und dann zumindest nur dieses Ausdrüten aus den letzten Spielen nochmal umkehren kann. Aber wenn man in der Form von Union jetzt nach Gründen sucht, dass sie dieses Spiel gewinnen werden, ist es relativ schwierig, aber erstens hat man eben auch in den jetzt nicht so guten Spielen gesehen, was da noch besser sein könnte und besser kommen könnte und über den HSV haben wir auch schon gesprochen.
Okay, dann lassen wir kurz die Aufstiegsaspiranten abrunden, indem wir noch kurz über Heidenheim und Kiel sprechen. Heidenheim mit 49 Punkten noch direkt an der Verlosung dran, das heißt zwei Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz. Kiel, da sind es schon fünf Punkte, du hast mir aber im Vorgespräch gesagt, lass die schon auch ruhig noch mit reinnehmen. Was gibt es denn zu den beiden Mannschaften zu sagen, außer dass es natürlich eine brisante Story wäre, wenn Heidenheim gegen Stuttgart in die Relegation müsste, aber davon abgesehen?
Also bei Heidenheim kann man das glaube ich dann doch noch relativ kurz machen und auf den Trainer Schmidt und auf Mark Schnatterer verweisen und darauf, dass die tatsächlich ihre Expected Goals doch ein bisschen deutlicher overperformen, wie übrigens auch Paderborn. Aber bei Paderborn fühlt sich das irgendwie systematisch gerechtfertigter an als bei Heidenheim.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Schmidt und Schnatterer – best love story since Twilight.
Genau, da sind noch ein paar andere Spiele, die ganz gut passen, aber grundsätzlich ist es einfach eine Mannschaft, die grundsolide ist und dann in so einer Saison, wo einige andere der Mannschaften, die davor stehen, ein bisschen mehr wackeln, dann immer noch irgendwie so Kontakt hält und ja eigentlich eher so eine Saison spielt, die für einen guten Mittelfeldplatz reichen oder einen oberen Mittelfeldplatz reichen sollte.
Ich meine, die Abwehr ist halt sehr – also wenn du sagst grundsolide, dann sprichst du ja vor allem auch über die defensive Absicherung. Man hat die drittbeste Abwehr der Liga, hinter der Union und dem HSV.
Genau. Und bei Kiel ist es eben so, dass die jetzt unter Tim Walther noch ein bisschen verrückter im Fußball spielen als letzte Saison schon, gerade also wenn man ein Freund von ungewöhnlichen und interessanten Aufbausteffelungen ist, dann muss man auf jeden Fall Kiel gucken und schauen, was die Innenverteidiger da so anstellen. Deswegen sind sie auf jeden Fall eine der interessanteren Mannschaften der Liga. Ob das jetzt tatsächlich noch für den Aufstiegspreis reicht, ist jetzt schon natürlich bei 5 Punkten Rückstand schon sehr fraglich. Das eine Argument, das es dafür gibt, ist, dass eben zwischen Hamburg, Paderborn und Union noch viele Spiele gegeneinander anstehen und da auf jeden Fall ja noch Punkte liegen lassen werden, sodass Ben Kiel jetzt tatsächlich seine restlichen Spiele gewinnen würde, dass sie vielleicht nochmal eine Chance hatten und mit der Spielweise, die sie haben, kann man ihnen das grundsätzlich immer auch zutrauen, weil sie einfach unglaublich hohes offensives Potenzial haben.
Also es geht jetzt noch gegen Sandhausen, Duisburg, Dresden und Bielefeld für Kiel und man weiß ja, du hast ja gesagt, unter anderem Union steht noch vor Kiel, die werden ja noch ein paar Mal unentschieden spielen, da werden ja noch Punkte liegen gelassen. Wir könnten jetzt noch ganz, ganz viele Worte verlieren, man müsste eigentlich auch mal über den FC St. Pauli zum Beispiel sprechen, die in der Rückrundentabelle den vorletzten Platz inzwischen belegen und alle Hörerinnen und Hörer werden es ja wahrscheinlich mitbekommen haben, inzwischen auch mit Jules Luhukai einen neuen Trainer haben. Das müssen wir mal auf einen der nächsten Zweitliga-Kurzpässe verschieben, denn ich möchte jetzt mit dir noch über den Abstiegskampf sprechen. Welche Vereine würdest du denn da überhaupt mit dazu rechnen und wer ist da für dich bemerkenswert?
Also bemerkenswert ist natürlich zuallererst sind 1000, die schon ziemlich abgestiegen schienen und dann jetzt auf einmal vier Siege und zwei Unentschieden aus den letzten sechs Spielen haben.
Die einzige Mannschaft der zweiten Liga, die in den letzten sechs Spielen ungeschlagen geblieben ist.
Ja, das ist relativ auch überraschend und ein bisschen unerklärlich. Das hat angefangen – da kommen wir jetzt doch ganz kurz auf St. Pauli zu sprechen – mit 1. Sieg gegen Magdeburg und dann vor allem mit 4-0 gegen St. Pauli, dass irgendwie da eine Art Initiatio nur noch mal gewirkt hat. Und ich weiß auch gar nicht so, also es wirkt aber auf mich auch wie eine Mannschaft, die davor eben ein bisschen mehr Pech hatte, als sie danach dann, als sie eigentlich verdient hatte und wo sich das jetzt so ein bisschen ausgeglichen hat, denn so was grundsätzlich anderes kann ich da eigentlich nicht erkennen, nur dass es halt besser funktioniert. Und die haben ja jetzt schon vier Punkte Vorsprung auf Magdeburg, das heißt, gerade wenn man sich die Form von Magdeburg anschaut, ist es nicht mehr so ganz einfach zu sehen, wie sie die noch verspielen würden, diese Punkte. Das heißt, es sieht so aus, als ob es sich zwischen Magdeburg und Ingolstadt entscheiden wird, was den Regationsplatz angeht. Duisburg, Fetter hat zwar eigentlich punktemäßig auch noch Chancen, aber macht nicht so viel richtig den Eindruck, dass sie die auch nutzen können. Von daher würde ich den Abstiegskampf tatsächlich auf Magdeburg und Ingolstadt fokussiert sehen mit der Komplikation, die dazukommt, dass es in der dritten, die ja nicht ganz unbescheinlich ist, dass Halle dritter werden könnte. Und eine Relegation zwischen Magdeburg und Halle – ich weiß nicht, wer sich die wünscht, ich glaube weder Magdeburg noch Halle besonders und vor allem, wie du sagst, eine anatolische Polizei.
Ich glaube Rainer Wendt wünscht sich die zwei Relegationen ganz deutlich. Ja, wie sieht es denn aus, dass uns das erspart bleibt? Magdeburg hat ja auch einen Zwischenhoch, würde ich es nennen. Da gab es ja auch unter anderem einen aufsehenerregenden 2 zu 1 Erfolg in Hamburg beim HSV, aber jetzt eben aus den letzten zwei Spielen 0 zu 1 zu Hause gegen Darmstadt verloren und 0 zu 1 jetzt auch auswärts in Regensburg verloren, während eben hintendran bei Ingolstadt die Lichter schon auszuscheinen schienen und jetzt mit Thomas Oral auf einmal da Siege eingefahren werden. 4 zu 2 in Duisburg, 1 zu 1 gegen Holstein Kiel und jetzt 3 zu 1 in Bielefeld. Also Ingolstadt saugt sich ran.
Bei Ingolstadt muss man halt sagen, dass da ja zwischendurch mal für relativ kurze Zeit ihr ins Keller Trainer war und die Entlassung tatsächlich noch sehr viel harscher war als die damals bei der Union. Denn Ingolstadt hatte dann eine Phase, wo sie gegen Paderborn, gegen Köln, gegen Union gespielt haben und eigentlich in allen Spielen mindestens genauso gut waren wie der Gegner, aber alle Spiele verloren haben.
Ja, Fußball ist aber ein Ergebnis Sport, Daniel, komm.
Und dann gegen Sandhausen noch ein Last-Minute-Niedelagentor kassiert haben und dann musste Canada gehen. Aber da hat sich eigentlich schon angeregt, dass diese Mannschaft halt schon in der Lage ist, da auch Spiele zu gewinnen. Und das hat sie dann jetzt nochmal gemacht in auch gewinnbaren Spielen, die sie da jetzt in den letzten drei Partien hatten. Von daher zeigt der Trend auf jeden Fall nochmal nach oben. Aber Magdeburg ist halt auch nicht so schlecht. Also die haben ja auch ihren Trainer gewestet, den Aufstiegs-Trainer ausgetauscht gegen Michael Oenning. Also Jens Härtel war das vor. Und haben eigentlich auch ganz interessante spielerische Ansätze, wie es generell eigentlich so ist, dass gerade Fans, bestimmte Fans der Vereine, die ja gerade abgestiegen sind und jetzt auch weniger dominant sind, als sie sich das vorstellen würden, gerne die Liga ja so ein bisschen schlechtreden und ihre eigenen Niederlagen gegen so Vereine wie Magdeburg als Beweis dafür nehmen. In gewisser Weise auch. Aber das kann man natürlich auch einfach anders drum sehen und sagen, dass diese 2. Liga vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht ist und da auch in Mannschaften, die im Hintergrund dabei ein Drittel stehen, durchaus spielerische Qualität steckt und das trifft eben auf Dresden zu, auf Aue, mittlerweile sogar auf Darmstadt, oh Wunder, und eben auch auf Magdeburg. Also auch in Magdeburg kann man durchaus ein ansehnliches Aufbau-Spiel sehen. Es gibt auch da Spieler, die wirklich große spielerische Qualität haben. Jemand wie Turpitz zum Beispiel, der da Zehner ist, ist ziemlich torgefährlich und in der Lage, gute letzte Bälle zu spielen. Und deswegen sehe ich auch dadurch das Potenzial noch Sieg zu und ich muss da jetzt gerade selber mal das Restprogramm schauen.
Die spielen jetzt noch zu Hause gegen Fürth, dann auswärts in Bochum gegen Union und dann zu Hause gegen den zu diesem Zeitpunkt vermutlich schon aufgestiegenen 1. Genau.
Also ich würde sagen, wenn man da so zwei Spiele von gewinnt, könnte das schon reichen und das könnte ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Wie ist denn das generell? Was erleben wir denn gerade für eine Zweitligasaison? Wenn du jetzt schon davon sprichst, dass es im Abstiegskampf bei einigen Mannschaften spielerischer zugeht, als man es vermutet hätte und wenn wir gleichzeitig ja mit Köln und dem HSV auch zwei sehr prominente Erstligabsteiger hatten, ist das eine besondere Zweitligasaison. Leider hast du ja sehr viel Zweitliga-Erfahrung als Anhänger von Union Berlin. Wie würdest du die ganze Spielzeit so ein bisschen einordnen? Was ist das für eine Liga?
Also nachdem es ja letztes Jahr so eine absurde Tabellenkonzentration gab, in der irgendwie alle ungefähr gleich viele Punkte hatten, hat sich das zwar dieses Jahr ein bisschen mehr aufgespreizt, aber es ist ja trotzdem so, dass die Qualität relativ breit verteilt ist. Das sieht man ja auch daran, dass eben immer wieder Aufsteiger aus der dritten Liga gleich eine gute Rolle spielen können. Man sieht es vielleicht auch im Unterschied der individuellen Qualität dann zur Bundesliga, der in den letzten Jahren vielleicht auch eher noch gewachsen ist oder nur deutlicher wird, ich weiß es nicht.
Also sind sich 2. und 3. Liga näher geworden und die 2. hat sich kollektiv, und beide haben sich kollektiv von der 1. Liga entfernt.
Das wäre eine These, ja. Aber das sorgt natürlich für viel Bindendrama innerhalb dieser Liga. Wenn man sich die Formtabelle zu jedem Zeitpunkt anguckt, macht die eigentlich immer relativ wenig Sinn. Also man sieht da gleich viel Rot und Grün irgendwie in allen Tabellen teil.
Das stimmt wirklich. Ich tippe die 2. Liga seit dem Jahr 2000. Das ist quasi mein Bezugspunkt zur 2. Liga. Ein Tippspiel gegen meinen kleinen Bruder. Und sie ist un-tippbar. Also man kann viel auf Unentschieden setzen. Das ist immer eine gute Variante.
Ja, also ich finde, dass es dieses Jahr schon durchaus Spaß macht, dazu zu schauen, weil es eben schon ein paar Mannschaften mit eigener Charakteristik und ein paar Mannschaften mit Anspruch gibt. Und ich würde dieses Verfalls-Narrativ, dass es so unglaublich schlecht ist, da genauso wenig angebracht sehen, wie es dieses Jahr in gewisser Hinsicht bei der Bundesliga ja auch ist.
Gut, und das mit der besten Liga der Welt, das wollen wir jetzt hier auch nicht rausholen, dass sich die 2. und 3. Ligen ein bisschen von der 1. Liga abspalten. Das ist ja auch alles ökonomisch begründet, also da könnte man ja ganze Tribüngespräche zu machen, wo man das sehr gut herleiten könnte. Was sollen die Vereine denn auch machen, wenn einfach die finanzielle Schere so weit auseinandergeht? Jetzt haben wir über das Restprogramm von Magdeburg gesprochen, lassen uns noch kurz auf das sprechen, was den FC Ingolstadt noch erwartet. Ein Heimspiel gegen Dresden, ein Auswärtsspiel beim HSV, ein Heimspiel gegen Darmstadt 98, ein Auswärtsspiel bei Heidenheim. Das heißt, auswärts zwei Mal Aufstiegskandidaten und zu Hause zwei Mal Mannschaften, die es irgendwie dann mit einem Sieg klar machen könnten, dass sie nicht absteigen, aber sehr wahrscheinlich schon aus der Verlosung raus sind. Also Darmstadt hat ja aktuell zehn Punkte Vorsprung auf den Religationsplatz, bei Dresden sind es neun Punkte. Wie ist da so deine Prognose, wenn wir jetzt bei Magdeburgs sagen, zwei Siege wären da durchaus noch drin?
Also das mit dem Tippen von zweitlicher Ergebnisse hatten wir jetzt gerade schon.
Du kannst auch einfach sagen, ja zwei Siege wären da noch drin und dann wissen wir, okay gut, es wird ein enges Rennen.
Also ich würde das Over-Under für Siege von Ingolstadt da eher so auf anderthalb setzen. Das musst du erklären, Daniel. Also wenn man sich fragt, was ist die Zahl von Siegen, auf die ich wetten würde, wäre das eher eine als zwei, war was ich damit meinte. Und auch nicht mehr. Also ich würde vermuten, dass Ingolstadt gegen Dresden eher verliert, dass sie die Auswärtsspiele in Hamburg und Heidenheim eher auch verlieren und dann vielleicht gegen Darmstadt gewinnen. Das wäre so mein Gefühl, aber wie gesagt, das ist mit den Gefühlen und den Erwartungen bei dieser zweiten Liga, das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Also ich bin da viel, viel weiter weg von der zweiten Liga, aber ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, bei Ingolstadt, da hat sich jetzt tatsächlich was gedreht. Also jetzt gerade, dass man jetzt zum Beispiel in Bielefeld genauso ein Spiel gewonnen hat gegen eine Mannschaft, für die es um nichts mehr geht und wo vielleicht dann halt die berühmten 5 Prozent oder meinetwegen auch mehr fehlen, das fand ich schon, die Tore halbwegs zufällig zum Teil entstanden, aber da waren so Aktionen mit dabei, wo ich mir gedacht habe, okay, interessant, bei Ingolstadt, da geht vielleicht noch was. Und dann stellt sich die Frage, wie geht denn vielleicht auch noch beim MSV Duisburg was? Es sind drei Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz mit Magdeburg. Und trotzdem redet man irgendwie von Duisburg schon so wie von einem sicheren Absteiger. Was das sichere daran liegt, dass man jetzt zum Beispiel aus den letzten sechs Spielen vier Unentschieden und zwei Niederlagen geholt hat, aber immerhin ja auch vier Unentschieden, also Union appreciates. Also der Theorie nach ist ja Duisburg auch noch in der Verlosung.
Ja, wenn man da halt nochmal aufs Restprogramm schaut, Amina Bielefeld, über die wir jetzt gar nicht gesprochen haben, aber die auch eine ziemlich gute Saison spielen, mittlerweile unter Uwe Neuhaus. Kiel, Heidenheim und Hamburg, das ist halt schon relativ schwierig.
Okay, gut, das Restprogramm ist der Grund, warum man über Duisburg spricht als fast sicheren Absteiger. Und was wäre dann so deine Einschätzung, woran hat es dann gelegen, dass Duisburg in diesem engen Abstiegsrennen sich nicht irgendwie so wirklich aus dem Kälten wieder befreien konnte? Ich glaube ja in keiner Phase dieser Saison.
Ich glaube, dass da einfach die individuelle Qualität nicht unbedingt da war und auch eben es keinen Faktor, keinen Systematischen gab, der da einen großen Unterschied gemacht hätte. Und dann ist der einzige Spieler, den ich bei Duisburg immer so für latent gefährlich halte in der 2. Liga, Oliver Kaule de Sousa. Ich glaube, das ist die richtige Reihenfolge der Namen und das ist eben auch ein Spieler, der relativ streaky ist, also der gute Phase und weniger Effektive hat. Und da fehlt, glaube ich, dann einfach in vielen Spielen irgendwie die Qualität, die zu gewinnen, wie du ja mit den Unentschieden gerade schon erwähnt hast, auch wenn man dann 4 Tore gegen Köln schießt.
Das ist echt 2. Liga. Also Duisburg, wir erinnern uns, sind vor zwei Jahren aufgestiegen, dann letzte Saison auf dem siebten Tabellenplatz gelandet und jetzt eben aktuell auf dem letzten Platz und mit dem Restprogramm eben gegen Kiel, gegen Heidenheim, gegen den HSV. Sieht das gerade nicht so wahnsinnig gut aus für den MSV. Ja, damit haben wir doch die Liga doch halbwegs kompakt schnell durchgesprochen. Gibt es noch einen Punkt, nachdem du jetzt vorhin schon gesagt hast, bei Kiel, da soll man sich mal den Aufbau aus den Innenverteidigern angucken. Das ist ein typischer Daniel-Rossbach-Satz. Wunderbar. Gibt es noch irgendwas zu einem Team, über das wir jetzt nicht gesprochen haben, wo du sagen würdest, achtet mal darauf, wie die den kurzen Pfosten bei einer Ecke besetzen. Das ist echt faszinierend. Kannst du uns noch den Mund wässrig machen.
Bei Dynamo Dresden spielt seit ein paar Spieltagen Trennish Burnec auf der Sechs, den man vielleicht so ein kleines bisschen aus Dortmund kennen könnte. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der da mal signifikant Bundesliga gespielt hat oder eher noch als Talent fungiert hat. Das ist auf jeden Fall so ein Beispiel dafür, wie interessante Spieler in dieser Liga aufploppen und dann auch interessante Dinge tun. Also in Dresden kann man sich ganz gut angucken unter Christian Fiel und das, was die im Mittelfeld machen und den spielischen Ansatz da insbesondere.
Ach Wahnsinn, Daniel. Das hat sehr, sehr großen Spaß gemacht, mit dir über die zweite Liga zu sprechen. Das war Daniel Rossbach. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank dir.
Schön, dass es diese Sendung jetzt auch mal gab.
Ja, da werden wir sehen, wie viel Gegenseitigkeit da bei den Hörern und Hörern zu finden ist. Bei dieser Freude. Mir hat es auf jeden Fall Spaß gemacht. Man kann dich hören im Textil vergehen. Man kann dich lesen auf eiserneketten.de oder bei der Lausisse Rundschau. Und man kann dir folgen auf Twitter at da unterstrich Rossbach mit Doppel S. Ja, und das war er dann, der Kurzpass zur zweiten Liga. Wenn ihr das hier schnell gehört habt, dann beglückwünsche ich euch dazu. Denn morgen kommt schon der nächste Kurzpass. Bis dahin macht's gut liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.